THE NEW YORK RANGERS.
HE COVERS.
LIKE THEY DO. IN TO INTERCEPT.
SUZUKI NAVIGATES NEUTRAL ICE MUH
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE CANADIENS
WEREN'T WINNING.
HE SAID IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR HIM
ATTACK
WORKS.
IT'S NOT CLEAN YOU KNOW HOCKEY ,
GA BUT MAATTA
TO KUPARI, THEY COULDN'T MAKE
IT.
>> Alex: OVER THEO THE NET COMEG
FROM BY CHIAROT. THIS.
SEE HOW QUICKLY THAT WENT ACROSS
LEMIEUX CANCELED HIS MAN BEHIND
THE NET. IN
PRACTICE YESTERDAY.
KNOWN FOUR.
LEFT HIS
CAREER.
MONTREAL PICKING UP A PENALTY.
POWER PLAY.
KNOCKED OFF THE TOP OF THE NET,
OFF A STICK AND LANDING ON TOP
EE
PUCK, GET UP ON THE
DANAULT UP THE WALL.
IAFALLO TO SIMILAR
ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THE SCREEN,
LOOK AT
DANAULT PINNING SUZUKI TO THE
THE PAST
COMING OR BACKING PEOPLE UP.
MAATTA STARTED, SPINS,
>> Alex: THEONEN IN PURSUIT FOR
MONTREAL.
HERE IS KUPARI. RUSH.
WHEN IAFALLO RECEIVES THE PASS
ON ENTRY, WATCH THE
SUZUKI MOVES UP ICE.E.
FREE TO ANDERSON.
SAVED BY PETERSEN.
>> Jim: CHIAROT SHOWED US THAT.
HE CAN FIRE THE PUCK.
THIS ISG
THTH BY PETERSEN.
>> Jim: NICE MOVEMENT